aa c'est à dire ça y est nega c'est vrai
je sai et j'irai dernier deux semaines
de vacances ça y est c'est fait rousseau
a oui alors c'est pas déjà trois
semaines de retard il
s'en fout
je pars plus du tout à mykonos à savoir
c'est un jour vu retirer en eau par deux
semaines déjà en thaïlande ferme boxe
thaï
qui se fait
forcément musculaires anormaux
pour l'instant je suis seul à retenir
jabal un
massage
pour l'instant je suis seul ya des
serpents
général et des serpents synthé pas peur
de rien il ya plein de rhode island je
peux prendre un certain
temps je me rappelle et je suis déjà là
une fois en thaïlande ça ouais je suis
parti tout seul en taille non mais ça
fait partie déjà seul en thaïlande je
vous jure que c'est vrai ça j'ai genre
25 ans je suis partie seule en thaïlande
j'allais pas partir j'étais en jamais
voilà j'avais j'avais toujours chez plus
t'es pas cher il ya un voyage qui était
organisée truc mes parents voilà vous
voulez mais plus trop le temps de parler
et
je vous jure l'histoire est vraie et
j'arrive dans la non je suis seul et je
suis à côté d'un mec amy tu parles je
vais j'y vais j'ai pas d'hôtel j'ai rien
je suis seul l'aventuré elle je décide
de partir en thaïlande seul c'est pas
une balle puis l'animateur s'est plaint
de ses plats dits matters élément
suspect david à quoi j'ai jeu de médias
dont je parle bizanos va et vient avec
la côte est mbi et mini tube genie tu
pars ou et oui mais voilà je parlais une
dictature par luigi moi je pars là je
vais faire ça fait plus tard bref
attention parce qu'il ya un français qui
s'est fait corriger la sonara
ce fait on peut repartir sur padam padam
la blanche non non et donc là le mec me
chauffe tout fric et oui j'arrive là-bas
et je suis avec un gars ils prennent
tout tout le travail était go to pocket
armes pour qatar ou watch les dispos
keita on appris jeudi freire déjà je
vais déjà essayer de trouver un hôtel
qui m'a laissée en ville je suis allé
vers une trouve un hôtel etc le soir je
trouve un hôtel et le soir je sors seule
je vous assure que c'est vrai qu'un
matin on fout je me retrouve seul mais
c'est pas une 26e en boîte en thaïlande
il est
vrai avec je vous jure que l'histoire
est vraie et qu'à la limite à les seuls
bons mais aller seul en temps bourré je
crois que même ma mère découvre
l'histoire landaise elle doit dire vrai
on se gare sur ma vie et je suis partie
seule en boîte en thaïlande
je suis en thaïlande seul en te vois
comment en
parler là il ya des meufs qui viennent
me voir ils s'érigent pas trop céder
mais des meubles
l'histoire est en veille sauvé et son
ami histoire vraie je me retrouve et
d'histoires vraies je suis à 4 heures du
matin assis sur un bon nombre avec une
meuf qui me les pages et pascal dit
enfin en train de manger un truc d'eskom
décès par des trucs de ouf comme ça il
ya des trucs comme à nos jours quoi la
sortie de boîte à des trucs qu'ils
voulaient des prises et moi je suis
comme à ce faire bizarre et à un moment
mon frère je suis comme as rien gars qui
vient me voir et ne détient pas monter
sur mon scooter
sur ma belle histoire est vrai quoi
aller où je me retrouve on sait pas quoi
la cantonade chez mon ami et je me
retrouve derrière sur d'ailleurs à
thaïlandais s'est pas joué mon frère
est vrai c'est
vrai que moi
[Rires]
je suis resté trois jours un seul à la
barre bénéfices et qu que débarquent en
masse j'étais tout seul dans la bible un
ouf j'ai par la personne et tous les
soirs sortait sol comme un ouf en
thaïlande et s'est rien passé
je ne laisserai sait combien de temps à
nab a rejeté trois jours à 3 semaines au
noirmont je sais pas ce que j'ai fait
exprès gp tak tak joueurs qui avaient
fait le tour du splm et d'haricots là
bas je suis parti avec le gars
commencent avec un mmo dans ma tête et
après je suis rentré j mais qu'est-ce
qu'il a pris ce que fulham qui se fait
là
j'étais pas connu l'époque imaginons
maintenant lui a greffé sais pas
0e c'est pas toi je crois même mois pour
moi ça ne
ressemble fortement à
contrer l'amour pendant ces trois jours
alors pas du tout rouge syrien rencontré
du touât non non non je ne suis
franchement désolé j'ai fait que du
sport oui j'étais cependant à faune et
la flore et là j'ai décidé de partir
deux semaines mais là c'est un camp
d'entraînement je vous jure que c'est
vrai vous savez que mme élise s'il
connaît bien car si elle y va
régulièrement alors j'avais juste un
truc je me demande et je le demande aux
téléspectateurs
je me suis est ce que je me fais pas
alors je vous jure que c'est vrai chez
deux des liens
je voulais me raser la tête et de faire
un serpent tu as tout ici est magnifique
bien sûr pour partir
[Rires]
les niveaux d'eau par année aux usa et à
part la banane ananas joli bras vous
raser la tête c'est là j'irai j'irai
avec là je vous le dis je suis déjà allé
voir le tatoueur mais non j'ai mon rôle
et je le dis aux téléspectateurs faire
un serpent ici comme masque et à part ça
ça va
même si
gaga regarde ces news envoie un
narcotrafiquant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
passé alors volé ces cinq heures
d'entraînement par
le feu non après je pars en stage de
paddle et alicante eux sont
complémentaires non d'abord d'abord
traitement fils d'abord si le jeu
jusqu'à cette idée
après vous et je me détendre c'est en
habit compte pour le régime alimentaire
c'est pas mieux de faire d'abord
l'espagne après la thaïlande des vapeurs
de la ba de manger des choses et d'après
dario leïla j'ai fini leur dire
d'être là les gars là je suis à 174
abbaoui ne laisse déjà ça faisait très
fier d'ars devenir 69 lol je le dis les
gars l69 c'est mieux je vais m'entraîner
comme un fou avec le serpent ici
j'aime les gens du le cancer le penser
ici quand même alors qu'est ce qu'on dit
ce projet
je demande au public déjà book n'avait
pas peur de choquer votre public avec un
serpent sur la tronche nature dire à des
gens dont le site
[Rires]
donc je vois pas la porte alors moi je
vous vois vraiment partir mais j'ai
changé par là mais je sais très bien ce
serait parce que je qui veulent venir je
vais lui réglé il ya déjà de trois
personnes qui sont chaudes c'est à dire
vous allez voir
qu'il n'ya qu'elle y fait chaud dia lui
a voulu voir bush ou mais dans un autre
hôtel atego
voilà un objet de se raser la tête et de
faire un certain russie le serpent alors
serpent obligatoire
sinon tu peux tu peux y est voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je vous dis je te projet en revanche
m'assure pour le crâne rasé et le
serpent mais partir nous entraîner c'est
votre passion en ce moment vous êtes
afin au sport sport soit voilà donc
faire d'abord un côté très physique puis
après le paddle ça vous venez les crues
toi je te vois grave est que chaque fois
aussi sur ma vie un serpent qui tombe en
vidéo gag
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un
savant qui mets ton doigt
brad et moi de lui je fais la rencontre
non tu peux pas toi et ton un carton
jaune icc la série non mes frères je
vais te ramener toi tu bats contre ça si
je n'ai
pas le choix je vais être avec le boulet
faire
je connais m
[Rires]
c'est vrai que c'est un peu décevant
lunettes comme ça
jamais ce jour qui leur est proposée ce
week end j'ai failli s'appeler et je me
suis dit dangereux avec sa jambière
parce que là je vais te dire comme ça
c'est pour que tu reviennes commence à
faire je connais ça tu connais les clubs
pour le premier contre vingtaine de
boxes à chevaux
je connais est toujours agréable on n'en
profite pas
et tu leur envoie plusieurs mecs mais
fort on tapait
ont peu voire pas de quoi faire du
château
vraiment pas réfléchi mais pour
l'instant je suis pas très chaud dans
une structure un vrai truc bien sûr la
future structure palace
moi je fais tu chantes tu peux faire la
tige de bambou cancale
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
guez
et chaud ça arrive par contre c'est
qu'un certain on s'attire hypermnésie
tout me va mais là pas d'avoir fait
d'abord un pigeon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je me vois déjà toi toi je te vois
avec moi en vérité le seul que je veux
avec moi c'est toi je t'ai dit la vérité
à auxerre j'en appelle sur les rêveurs
de voir et je te jure je te vois avec
moi mais pour l'instant ça tu es dans
les prochains
mois sachez le thé dans mon arrivée les
pieds penser c'est une petite bosse et
pignons et mamad voilà que des galettes
shebab ont attaqué trois je
vous parlais anglais tellement bien oui
c'est vrai
calmos caraïbes aux
galeries invitées raymond du coup si
bien sûr remettre un petit peu écoute
moi bien ces combats sont la semaine
d'euros cadeau quand je croise et 5 sans
mal des deux semaines berlin
s'est rien passé
avec hébergement
au
pcb rejouera plus entraînements plus
combien de ce repas 500 balles
cinq heures par l'avion c'est combien
d'heures je sais plus et beaucoup mais
j'avais le lycée j'étais à côté d'un
gars d'état côté manga il a eu le temps
de me dire qu'ils avaient 18 morts la
semaine dernière ok je peux bien vous
faites début juillet un début juillet je
suis un quartier chaud sur battant le
jury réchaud toi sur toi je te dis rien
mais guillaume jeu
pour des soucis
d'assurance
touzit acheter tout moi mais tu
t'emmerdes pastèque peut-être pas tout
va bien le soir pour les animaux soit
toi tu seras ris parce que tu vas faire
tu vas pas faire entrer mais voilà toi
on va te mettre dans un hôtel cinq
étoiles à côté
quand un coup de mou
mais sans déconner c'est ça l'histoire
non mais vous allez faire beaucoup de
sport j'ai rien fait d'autre ma soeur a
titré l'occurrence je pourrai enfin
palper vos cuisses
ça y est
c'est bon ça y est alors conseillé au
moins voilà c'est
non mais si vous entendez non c'est bon
je joue
benhaim parler oui mais j'ai
l'impression qu effectivement et leurs
fenêtres
les boules
qui n'a jamais roulé une pelle à un pote
moi moi moi franchement faire mais moi
et ça n'arrivera jamais c'est pas de
honte à cela je comprends pas ma part je
dors en cuir avec mes amis que je suis
bien
[Rires]
c'est quoi la dijonnaise to
die je lâche tout évidemment qu'une
arrivée au lot samarie oui ah ouais
j'avais dormi en cuir avec un copain
je vais terminer en cuir cousu
j'avais compris en cuir en cuillère
c'est à dire quoi j'avais compris lé en
cuir ça va quoi sinon
ça va sinon tout va bien ça va au milieu
qui recèle encore un je ne sais pas tu
es en thaïlande qu'est ce qu'il a il
part dans les landes
je ne connais pas encore mon traitement
quoi elle dans mon job c'est pas moi
explique on n'a rien fait ou
non mais ça il voulait venir bouffe oui
moi je serai là
guichanné soit le repos du niari moi
même étant
génération chilien
j'adore et là franchement j'suis pas car
c'est le compagnon idéal n'y a qu'à toi
tu échoues permettre aux motards ce jour
là avec moi je t'invite voilà paris
début juillet je me suis inscris choix
je parle de cinq des leurs un gars
qu'est ce que tu lis excuse moi je
comprends pas ce
qu'est ce que tu n'y vas pas de boxeur
français qui sont à bord y ait une
bourgogne mais alors tu es chaud tu
venir dans son ranch où on
l'attend l'équipe commence à ressembler
à quelque chose c'est
[Rires]
mokhtar et moi et j'en conviens mais il
ya quelque chose d'aussi la mala faut
filmer à ayem guillaume genton le soir
c'est à dire une équipe on la comprend
pas la meilleure mais qu'elle y seront à
la piscine en attendant voilà c'est fait
et je pense que tant qu'il sera vite à
la piscine la tendance
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]